hi this is a science angle from science
mission i'm Sadashiva pi a dr. TJ
Icefall with us is the associate
professor in the department of genomics
and pediatrics at the George Washington
University School of Medicine dr.
jaiswal has more than 40 publications to
his credit figure he is a member of
several societies and has mentored
several individuals or for many journals
also and he has been about that several
grants to his credit view let's welcome
dr. J's 12:00 welcome dr. J thank you
thanks for joining
science hangout let's get going
yourself like your background career
your education everything so my training
will use as a biologist and I have
trained in various forms of microbes I
have really been interested in various
sorts of technologies and their
applications so my initial training was
in India I did my masters from Baroda
and then PhD from Ministry of Science is
in Bangalore focusing primarily in
developmental biology looking at
organisms from the standpoint of cells
to whole organism and then got more
interested in applying technologies
worked in the field of developing
nanoparticles and other kinds of small
molecule based probes personal probes
for imaging purposes then developing
microscopy approaches for high
resolution imaging and at that time I
sort of got interested in when I was at
Rockefeller doing this work Rockville
University New York doing this work I
got interested
and things that I've since pursued in my
own career here at George Washington and
initially in tell us about your lab your
lab members like a handful of people
it's about six to eight people at any
given time but my lab has there are two
graduate students and those starts but
there's a that's part of my group
responsible for excuse me pardon me I'm
coming off a call so you'll keep hearing
it more frequently than I should
normally but what can I do is in
addition to they're in highly
collaborative in nature so elaborate
with clinicians and basic scientists as
well as mouston ed cysts and proteomics
homeless people with regards to
developing the tools and techniques that
we currently have two answers questions
about tissue entry information for
disease purpose for understanding
diseases and for curing diseases so
don't there's a strong focus of my work
at the moment on muscle diseases but the
work that I've been doing has been
relevant and has been applied to brain
injury other kinds of tissue injury as
well so we really are focusing towards
developing different sorts of basic
science understanding and preclinical
and clinical applications of this to
worse understanding how chronic diseases
related to tissue injury and repair
deficits can be handled understood
including and I know you are a busy
person writing grants taking care of
different projects and all so can you
talk to us about a little bit about your
other than the lab activities like do
you do your hobbies your interest so
yeah
I'm fascinated being a microscopy which
is one of the things that I I do as a
hobby as job as a profession I am very
interested in capturing nature so I
enjoy spirulina that I used to be
primarily and ask a photographer before
but since then divers but also taking
pictures of human the human nature's and
I really focused more on capturing
moments rather than capturing video so I
enjoy put that for a bit I like I think
and go both walking and jogging and
treehouse and so I enjoy going in nature
whatever in capturing nature in that
manner or using my camera oh okay and
can you talk us about any role models or
any mentors you have in your career that
helped you so yeah I've been very
fortunate in having a series of very
good mentors and they have really been
the reason why I am in the position that
I am right now being able to think and
critically evaluate both my and other
people's work so I great deals to all of
these mentors and I won't start naming
all of them but from my undergrad that
is to my postdoctoral days people who
who have mentored me and trained me have
been very valuable in like my own
thinking and my ability to pursue
science the way I do but I later
realized I have found a new set of
mentors as I have gone out of my
educational phase to what people
consider as the mentorship face
I find that now the students are my
mentor first year so I've been very
fortunate to have wonderful students and
also the training I important them in
the cleaning day important to me I hope
I can pursue to learn from and continue
to aspire towards becoming better than
what I am what they would want for me to
be in the days to come so I think at the
moment I would say my biggest mentors
are my students okay that's nice to know
and let's talk about your work
and you have been doing some mutton
muscle related world muscular diseases
and all those things yeah can you please
talk about some work
sure so very briefly mentioned the
interest I develop in muscle diseases
and then can go on to it to the side
part of it it really I've always been a
basic scientist in Christian and treat
my basic questions and developing
techniques and technologies to address
them but during one of the worst about a
world a terrible now at the Children's
Hospital in Washington DC I was taken by
a conversation I had patients and just
the patients that were there as I was
walking up to go get my top on the fifth
floor and that sort of didn't was one of
the turning moments in my life that I
realized that there is more to
understanding science there is more to
it than just having a basic you Gosling
there's more to it every of application
and muscle diseases caught my interest
for various reasons at that time but it
has ended up being a wonderful model for
what what it can teach us about this
change because it's very unique in its
ability to both repair itself and
regenerate completely like unlike most
herbs teachers in our body and it not
only does that but thrives on being
injured and repairing from it so it's a
wonderful model system to study and
understand the basic sciences of the
tissue injury and repair process 72
changing and repair process and then
apply it hopefully to other kinds of
diseases which we are finding and
however fish on that briefly in the talk
itself which I'm planning is the case
that discoveries that we are making with
muscle model really is relevant to many
other models in the other tissue models
so that's not my foray into muscle
diseases and I'm really hopeful that
there is going to be a moment in my life
and some of the work that we're doing
can translate into clinic and I will
give you a few examples of how you
really make inroads into being in
clinical ready that's all of these
things I'm getting close to it yeah
please go ahead and present your work
sure okay
so I able to see my screen now and not
yet okay
yeah okay so what I'll really talk about
would be about self survival and the
mechanisms that are involved in the
process ourselves survival by using
muscle in the model system so what you
see in the background of this is my
image of a Maya fiber as I said the
things if you discovered by using muscle
tissue has been relevant to other other
cell models as well so this is you can
sort of take most of it that I will
describe today as relevant to many other
cells so let's start with the very
fundamental question of what happens to
a cell in response to an injury of some
sort and this is sort of a cartoon
showing how a mechanical trauma is
disrupting the the lipid bilayer this is
the membrane bilayer what that does to a
cell and response to this trauma is
you'll start to get influx of
extracellular material inside the cell
and a flux cellular material outside the
cell so one of the major things that the
glassy membrane provides a patio floor
is iron and water the influx of iron and
water ions like calcium and if lots of
materials like ATP other kinds of
cellular compartments proteins are both
detrimental to the survival of the cell
but also the functioning of the membrane
itself and this is sort of an example
where which illustrates some of the
different events that can happen as a
result of this just from the act of
calcium entry I to get excess water
entry the cell will explode if you get
excess calcium entry you'll have all of
these different pathways activated so it
if not controlled
if this membrane damage is not
controlled that'll lead to the death of
the cell so much of what we talked about
with the Constitution injury really
initiates at the level of a cell being
injured that's the first few minutes of
the show interior cell injury and what
happens as a response to it then decides
that tissue will degenerate or
successfully repaired from it and the
work that we've been doing really is it
the question is - what happens to the
cell and how the cell deals with this
initial event and disimpact leading to
damage in plasma membrane and copes with
this damage by repairing it so this is a
question that people have thought about
for a long time this is not a novel idea
there's a quote from Victor hydron from
1930 where he says it's indeed
remarkable fact that protoplasm on
emerging formed cells undergoes at
reactions so essentially similar to that
[ __ ] blood undergoes when it emerges
from a blood vessel and that's what I've
just captured that thought over here is
his drawing a parallel between blood
clotting and total doesn't clotting if
you will so that was one of ideas that
was renowned that protoplasm somehow
gels as a result of damage to blossom
membrane forming sort of blood
lightening the blood cells are forming
here but the current form in which we
think of this process of repairing
damage to the membrane is less focused
on this clotting although no one's
disproven it it's not it's not that the
mainstream thought the mainstream
thoughts are really from the work of
rich Reinhard's and Paul McNeill and
couple of other people who led this
field back in the early 90s
it has identified a few different
mechanisms or models you can go of how a
membrane damaged membrane can repair if
it's a small tear the line tension of
that on the lipids will allow the
membrane to recede back up quickly if
it's a larger tear or devour micron then
you will have these blue stripes which
are the actin filaments and the black
part which is remembering itself
coordinating by way of intracellular
compartment vesicles to fuse and provide
the additional membrane that will allow
the damaged membrane to grow back and
heal on itself or form a patch that
would then put a band-aid if you were on
the hole and seal up the membrane so
there's evidence of match formation from
workings and other saw sites and other
kinds of model there's evidence from
both mammalian cells and other kinds of
cells that's in individual vesicles can
fuse
but it's not clear if one or the other
mechanism is what's being used if these
are the only mechanisms being used is
slotting another mechanism or other
other events other kinds of processes
that go on that help a damaged cell
membrane repair itself so these are sort
of the broad questions that needed to be
understood in order for us to know what
kind of genetic or other cellular
defects can lead to poor repair of
damaged cells and then lead to tissue
injury that becomes a chronic tissue
damage so that's been one of the focus
of the work that we've been doing now if
you think of the tissues where the
damage happens there are a variety of
mechanically active tissue where the
cells are constantly damaged you can
think of long you can think of God there
you think of this cardiac tissue
skeletal muscle all cells are capable or
enough prone to injury but these are
mechanically very active cells so they
get injured much more so than others so
in this cartoon here there's a depiction
of how a cell membrane of a Maya fiber
or muscle schedule muscle fiber can get
damaged as a result of activity and what
the cell what the models are with you
guys - what this - then do so a few
important things to keep in mind here
which I'll come back and refer to again
later in the talk so I'll just point
them out also here you have the
extracellular matrix which is the
basement membrane under which the blue
line here which is the plasma membrane
of this Maya fiber is it contact with
through this protein complex of the
dystrophin glycoprotein complex it
stabilizes by interaction of the
extracellular matrix through plasma
membrane to the myofibril the cart in
the element that contracts and allows
the muscle fibers to contract upon
stimulation all of them to be in sync
when there is a mechanical activity if
you lose the dystrophin protein which
leads to the disease called this
addition muscular dystrophy DMD then you
break the link between the house and an
inside and then can that can lead to
increase tears in the membrane I'll talk
about this disease there's not a disease
where you have a stroke he called this
Verdun which is involved thought to be
more than vesicle fusion or some sort of
a membrane remodeling event if that's
missing then you can have these
remembers of the vesicle patches
technology about they could be missing
and that could lead to poor repair and
there's an evidence for that from this
paper about 15 years ago from Kevin
Campbell's lab where he identified that
myofibers that lack this werden repaired
poorly bleeding do an increased amount
of dye Henry the dye that is in this
model that laser is focused on these
spots right here and the injury in a
healthy fiber prevents the dye from
entry very rapidly so you haven't find
these little spot there but if you
injured either an absence of calcium so
the calcium is not there to trigger the
repair response and the fiber healthy
fiber fails to repair and the news for
an adult I were similarly fails to
repair even men that is calcium even
when the signal is coming in a inverse
calcium the fiber does not manage to
repair very efficiently so in diseases
of muscle and other tissues if the if
the repair response is deficient you
will get more fiber death or more cell
death and that was that was sort of the
crux of this paper arguing as to how
this wording might be more in repairing
the my fiber and lack there off leads to
the disease leads to this muscle
dystrophy so the same general
architecture exists in other tissue
types and other cell for other selves
too and so you can sort of see that the
parallel between a repair pathway that
might involve destruction of the
membrane basement membrane loss membrane
and internal compartment linker or lack
of vesicles to fuse it to repair it so
one of the no Sutton lab rat here before
asked the question if this Verdun is
involved in the process of repair how is
it doing it what is its role is what I
described before with regards to install
SS patched formation is this
my which is fairing or there's there are
other additional roles because the role
of this world in per se has not been
fully delineated yet as to what this is
children these are all suggestions that
they might be forming a French so mmm
what she did was she looked looked at
cells from healthy donors and the limbs
were to be patients that is certain off
with the patient's patients who lacked
discordance routine and looked at in the
mire of lasts single cells and the
written the images here will show you
roughly what's going on but let me play
the video to show you what the repair
process looks like now this is an assay
I will repeat over and over again it's
that I am free and say that I is FM 143
i already referred to from Kevin
Campbell's dr. Kevin Campbellsburg
before that there is a laser injury in
this case it'll happen had these spots
marked by the green boxes and as a
result of injury you'll get dye that's
floating around in the media to start to
enter the cell and the entry will
continue as long as the cell fails to
repair as the cell is repairing once the
cell prepares the dye entry stops and
that's why you can see this plateau
effect a cell that fails to repair and
that's the example here where we've
knocked down distorted protein in these
in these cells here the dye include has
not stopped and she'll keep getting more
dye into the septum so this is no
healthy cell you get this injury and you
get tiny amount of dye entry here
there's a whole cell sitting over here
but the cell never really gets becomes
green whereas if you do the same sort of
an injury on a patient seller
disburdened efficient patient cell which
is the example here you'll get in
response to injury dye that keeps
entering and you can almost start to see
the whole cell here because the dives
filling up inside the cell is becoming
more and more green so this is this is
the laser injury acid it tells us that
these cells I can keep them of repairing
or keep poorly repairing and response to
this injury so the question that she
went out after was what is the mechanism
behind it what kind of vesicles or
vesicular pathways might
be involved in it one of the things that
already I noticed was in dispersion
definition cells both the knockout cells
from mouse or shRNA defeated cells or
patient cells that isn't decrease in the
number of lysosomes which are one of the
compartments that I've been implicated
in the process of repairing damaged
cells there's a decrease in number of
lysosomes that appear at the cell
surface which is marked by the staining
for the lysosomal marker lamp one see
when we look at the and destroy the
knockout cells there's much less lamp on
the surface of the injured cells so the
injured cells are marked by red dye that
has entered inside the cell and the
green dye is Lingala staining for lamp
one so that's significantly reduced as a
result of lack of this furnace so that
sort of led us to the model that maybe
vesicle fusion is reduced and as a
result of reduced vesicle fusion you're
not adding enough membrane and that
might be the reason for poor repair of
the dis foreign invasion cells so what
she did then went on to do was to and
all of this brought is published in this
articles and that's why I'm glossing
over many of the important technical
details but even the question has
especially have specific questions are
peaking we can talk about that but I
would recommend one or this article to
get a more detailed technical idea
behind this these experiments so what
she did was she looked in live cells to
ask is this just a decrease in total
number of lysosome well there's more to
it and 1 and B 2 is there a deficit and
ashfoundation are these vesicles truly
forming a patch and plugging the hole or
is there something else going on so what
she did what here was label
lysosomes with a green dye and by using
a microscopy approach called total
internal reflection fluorescence
microscopy which only illuminates about
200 nanometers of membrane $100
nanometers of membrane that is in
contact with the self with a color slit
we can look at only at the membrane
proximal event so she's only looking
here at the lysosomes that are sitting
at the cell membrane and by looking at
in
between vesicles so this is the example
here drawn for one vesicle she would see
if the vesicle fuses and Reese's content
one at a time or they all fuse together
to first form a batch and then the patch
goes to this site of injury and plug the
hole the expectation was with the patch
we will see one single fusion event
bolus here and if its individual fusion
events we'll see them spread all over
the cell so this video plays around
you'll see the injury happen here in a
few seconds and then you'll see the
response after individual vesicles to it
so you'll see now that the cells been
injured right there and you start to see
all of these vesicles are some vesicles
a few fusing whatever they're sitting at
they don't call this to the site of
injury and start to make a batch there
they just keep choosing wherever they're
sitting at and if she looks at the total
number of lysosomes that fuse
individualized some set fuse in response
to injury she found that was decreased
by default but surprisingly the decrease
was only in the first 15 seconds the
late latter events were all about the
same between the wildlife in the
knockout does for an interaction with
conditions for insufficient cells the
decrease was only in first 15 seconds so
that was very puzzling why is the
decrease only in fresh 15 seconds
relevant to repair is this causing poor
repair so one of the things that we
observed that hit with regards to this
was there's a as the amount of lysosomal
fusion decreased in the his friend
deficient cells the amount of lysosomal
enzyme released by the cell called the
acid sphingomyelin days was also
decreased so there is a if a decreased
fusion of lysosomes in the first 15
seconds that results in decreased
secretion of as the sphingomyelin a's
overall situation and that secretion
deficit we thought might be relevant
because it's a single minor name is a
lipid modifying enzyme attacks on swim
island so we thought maybe there is
something going on that you guys
modification that needs to happen within
the first 15 seconds and it's not a
patch model it's not a place where
membranes will fuse and form a band-aid
but something they did do something else
by fusing rapidly in the first 15
seconds
no what we found in response to that
line of thought was the sphingomyelin s
secretion may really end up being
relevant to the to the repair process
and if that is the case then we might be
able to reverse the deficit by providing
the sphingomyelin is even before making
the injury so that they're the single
man is is available outside within the
first 15 seconds when the muscle fusion
is deficient so we muscle fibers remised
that are deficient in this verdun so
they're called the block blast bb6
AMS oh gosh a mouse and we dip the
muscle fibre and injure them if you look
at the injury in a different definition
fiber much like what Campbell's la
lavage shall we saw dietary that both
significantly greater then the healthy
muscle fibers but then when we took the
same muscle fibers and pre treated them
with sphingomyelin eyes and this is
stills from this video right here it
shows the amount of dye included in this
world the first four minutes of injury
if you take the same a muscle and then
free clintonb its swing no matinees you
will see he responds to injury the
amount of by entry is significantly
reduced and the stills are over here
this shows the fat here shows the amount
of by entry for a wild type in green the
disparate efficient fibers in pink and
the destroyed and efficient fibers that
have been treated with Swingle myelin is
in orange so turns out that the vesicle
fusion is an important criterion or an
important role for this burden in
repairing vesicles but it's not just an
provision of membrane by the fusion of
lysosomes to the membrane in response to
injury but it's actually the secretion
of a single mile neighs deficiency in
which causes to a repair and if you can
sup
this becomes a therapeutic approach so
this is one of the therapies that we've
tested out in a preclinical model and
this isn't the drug itself -
collaboration with Pharma is isn't for
our different education isn't in the
clinical trial stage for that purpose so
if the preclinical models do end up
proving this value for functional
improvement then the clinical trials and
switches in phase 3 stage will hopefully
be will allow us to then transfer in
this quickly to the list for no traffic
patients so why we are doing this
experiment one of the things that we
noticed in the
laser injury as a floor looking at the
Maya fiber is the Maya fiber stem cells
as they are repairing and them don't
play this video to show this point as
they're repairing they secrete these
tiny little vesicles from the site of
injury and hopefully encash them now so
running away from the site of injury is
here's one here's another one a whole
bunch of them of running away now so as
the my fiber repairs closes the wound
the membrane itself has been shut off
the damaged membrane is being shut off
here and this this is another sort of
neat way of looking Eric that we've
taken the the first image of this video
and colored that green and the last
image of this video colored that red but
overlaying the pre-injury a post repair
images you can kind of see all these red
circles and vesicles that came out in
the large red vesicles that have formed
inside the damaged membrane so the act
of repair leads involves shedding of
membrane and there was a study that I
will not talk about that which I've
cited over here where we looked at role
of this protein called the s4 protein
and sorting complex protein and
recycling complex proteins that other
people have identified to be modern
processes such as exosomes formation the
in the multi vesicular body or HIV
budding or cytokinesis places where a
constricted membrane needs to be cut off
these proteins I used as corporal tees
are used and we found a role for the
proteins in shedding of these vesicles
and inhibiting that ended up inhibiting
repair of my fibers and fill my glass
and culture so not only do we need to
secrete enzyme through lysosomal
secretion to modify the membrane but we
also need to use these enzymes and other
processes in volume there's core complex
to shed membrane that's damaged in order
to allow the new membrane to heal and
close the wound up so this is a part
that I've really lost for very good
leads and there's some interesting
thoughts in this in this article now
refer your audience to take a look at
that if they're interested in the role
of membrane shedding and exosomes and
Hector's ohms in the act of membrane
repair but more importantly also in the
act of tissue inflammation and repair
okay so while you were doing this and
actually the the escort Burke came out
as a result of the proteomic stream that
was initiated by Nimisha camera who took
this approach of purifying proteins from
the cell membrane or enriching proteins
from cell membrane and asking in a cell
that has been that is not the injured
versus of that is injured what are other
proteins that are showing up at the
segment by doing that we can then expand
our palette of intracellular
compartments beyond just lysosomes which
were the only compartment that people
had talked about in the literature to be
involved in repair so we wanted to
actually find out if that is it or else
there are other compartments that are
inborn in the repair process and if
there are other processes involved in
repairing damaged cells so in this
strategy what she did was she pulled by
using a biotin tag for the cell membrane
proteins she pulled down membrane
proteins from these two population of
cells and ran them on a mass
spectrometry to compare what changed
from an uninjured and yourself she
identified in the myoblast
the escort proteins but in the myofiber
her work showed that the bulk of the
proteins appear coming down on
mitochondrial proteins and that was very
puzzling at the time we thought why
would mitochondria show up at the time
it's a membrane
but thinking back of literature turned
out this was not as really a surprises
it's just something that was not very
heavily investigated it has been
reported that as early as 1990s they're
broken grana grants lab in Australia
showed that when she would look at Ian's
images of damaged myofibers she would
see these stumps or the places where the
myofiber heals itself is completely full
of mitochondria mitochondria that it's
not damaged did they need they even had
neatly organized Christy and these
mitochondria seemingly functional
mitochondria had the stunk was a
consistent feature this is a rat muscle
but another muscle stew so we went back
and asked is this something that's
happening these were images taken
several hours after injury so it wasn't
clear if this these Eric Andre
accumulated at the site of injury later
in life of the Maya fiber after the
repair or during the course of repair so
we asked ourselves this question is
mitochondria has our mass spec data
showing us is mitochondrial humilating
at the site of injury right after the
injury itself so we took advantage of
live imaging mitochondria myofibers to
do so and this is showing you just a
couple of examples from stills as to how
Maya fiber looks before injury and that
is same for mitochondrial marker and you
can see mitochondrial accumulation right
at the site of injury upon injury and
this video illustrates that using the
same approach the my fiber is labeled
with mitochondrial die to live all
mitochondria that are active and then
there'll be a laser injury right here
show but the fate of the mitochondria is
you'll see in response to repeated
injury you get this accumulation of
mitochondria at that site and while
there is as the fiber moves the
mitochondrial fluorescence all over
seems to be increasing the increase
really is greatest at this site so
Nimisha report that in an article a few
years ago and what she also showed in
the same article was if you work
depolarize mitochondria by using this
model can be on comforter for Donna for
cccp
you'll get you get a dose-dependent
inhibition of repair as indicated by the
same F&I fluorescence increases assay
that I described earlier set five micro
motor versus gel micro motor and 10
micromolar the repair is almost as bad
as the repair in absence of calcium so
calcium is an important signal for
repair process and this is any
demonstration that depolarizing
mitochondria can give the same level
similar level of deficit has - calcium
scenario does so in response to an
injury you see as before nice
containment of my entry in a healthy
fiber but when you keep them in CCP the
Thai food he fills up the Maya fiber so
it's sort of remain as a puzzle for some
time as to what the mechanism behind
this mitochondrial involvement of repair
is atom horn registering in the lab took
up this project and decided to
investigate what the role of
mitochondria might be the repair process
so the first thing I saw was in response
to injury the mitochondria that are at
the site of injury rapidly take up
calcium so this is a calcium sensor that
is genetic ink or calcium sensor called
my trocar gecko in response to injury
the calcium increases here and all
throughout the cell gradually all
throughout the cell as well
but later on the calcium drops in the
back of the cell where as it continues
to stay high for the site of injury so
this is a trace off pad and the site of
injury you get this increase in a
gradual decrease but the back the
mitochondria in the back will flee
dropped down by this time to the basal
calcium before injury the mitochondria
here don't do that so at the site of
injury since mitochondria is increasing
in calcium
he asked could mitochondria be using
this calcium increase to initiate some
repair process one of the key control of
mitochondrial calcium pinkie's in
mitochondria calcium as this diagram
shows here is to activate the ATP
synthase synthetic pathway by acting at
different steps along the up along the
cycle so he thought maybe mitochondria
injury are taking of calcium and of
triggering calcium induced ATP
production and since it's an energy
intensive process maybe ATP is being
produced to simply repair and Adam
looked at that and I'll get to the ATP
data in a second before that I guess I
should just touch upon the importance of
calcium itself and to look at the role
of calcium itself in the process of
repair what he did was he looked at
cells that are deficient or that lack
calcium transporter MCU mitochondrial
calcium unit or her not yet and saw that
clearly as expected these cells don't
take up calcium the response to injury
so there's a significant reduction in
their ability to take up calcium in
response to injury and what that does it
causes the cytosolic calcium to increase
and to stay up longer so this is a
calcium sensor for the sinus off the
floor floor if you take cells that are
helps you knock out and look at its
calcium in the cytosol it stays up
higher for a longer period of time and
to a greater extent and if you've been
looking at the repair ability of these
cells by using the same FM die assay
whereas the why should I prepare in the
first 50 seconds then not MCU not have
continued dye entry and have there is a
three-fold increase in the number of MCU
knockout cells that and failed to repair
and that that indicated to us that this
calcium uptake ability of the cell is
critically linked to the repair process
so back to the idea of ATP ATP is
required for this process Adam took the
approach of inhibiting an ATP production
first by using either a if of glycolysis
two locks in DT D glucose or by using
azide to inhibit mitochondrial
respiration or by using a combination of
those two drugs to inhibit it you could
acute hitting production so these cells
have just been acutely treated with
these drugs to block ATP production and
the time of repair not chronically just
prepare and turns our doesn't matter
whether we treat them at one or other or
a combination of their there is no
difference in the repetitive here Michel
so that was a little surprising could be
thought ATP product but you dirty new
production must be needed for their
process of repair but turns out it is
the Basel ADP that exists inside of a
cell is sufficient to repair the cell
even if the cell does not have acute
increasing need to be production in
Reverse just fine so then what could
work with them role of mitochondria B so
if I can go back to this cartoon for a
second what the result of this increase
in the cycle petrol transport chain
while you get ADP as the main product
one of the site byproducts of this
process as a result of the electron
carriers donating that an electron can
causing oxidation his production of
reactive oxygen species so we ask
ourselves is there is an increase in
reactive oxygen species production in
response to injury by these might have
the other side of repair so Adam took
redox sensor and and monitored the level
of mitochondrial dross reduction so that
is started at two mitochondria and
looked at called mitosis and looked at
the redox level at the site of injury in
the way from threat of injury and sure
enough in response to injury you get
this heat map which shows a burst of
mitochondrial cross that he continues to
increase as cell tries to repair itself
so keep this in mind this is fairly
consistent with what we saw at the site
of injury the mitochondrial calcium goes
up and stays up and you're getting this
matrimonial cross going up and staying
up as well so he asked is this really
important or is this relevant for a pear
even so Adam took this drug drove known
that blocks complex one and causes
excessive matrix mitochondrial cross
production and saw with this or another
drug called onto mice in which does the
same job at a different complex of a
three that causes nipples ended up
causing greater - ox production and
shown here's the example of rotenone
actually got the FM die entry to stop
earlier than the healthy cells in the
untreated you get greater die and
treated or untreated acutely treat
yourself so increase in transiently
increasing under control ross production
was actually beneficial
unlike the ATP production ross
production most consequential for repair
process and he did the reverse expand
where he put drug combiner template
quench the mitochondria cross so that
whatever mitochondrial MCU needed
mitochondrial cross through calcium but
get produced will get quenched rapidly
by by this drug and that caused
increased reverse the phenotype caused
increased die entry and the the midas ox
production was significantly down in
this in this scenario so it just by
increasing Ross or by decreasing Ross in
the mitochondria it appears that it's
the mitochondrial cross that the calcium
is increasing which is facilitating
repair of the ATP itself so this is
interesting because it was again very
counterintuitive in there
Ross is thought to be in muscle and
other tissues thought to be a
detrimental signal it's something that
causes damage but in this acute model it
actually appears to be beneficial for
the process of cell survival so he asked
what whiterose be doing and one of the
things that being that i mentioned in
the model de for from on sign hard and
others were can work of built a men's
lab is that you get rapid active
depolymerization and polymerization at
the site of injury and their work
suggests that this might facilitate bat
formation but the act of actin
depolarization and repolarization has
not been fully investigators to what the
mechanisms there might be behind it so
we one of the things that mitochondrial
Ross has we shown to do in literature is
to alter act in colonization so we first
asked can we see actin polymerization
and depolymerization and is that
dependent on mitochondrial calcium
uptake so this is using effect and
reporter for life act
and cherry if you just look at this
zoomin of this region of the cell as it
undergoes repair you get a large burst
of effect an accumulation loss and then
bursts of effect an accumulation at the
site of repair and if you take them so
you knockout cells they are clearly
compromised they show the drop in effect
in as a result of injury but they never
build a top as the wife's type does not
only do we see this correlation with the
calcium uptake but by either the same
agents atomizing and minor temper to
increase mitochondrial cross or decrease
mitochondrial cross ingest my tempo we
can mimic the phenotype so he was able
to show that atomizing caused a slightly
greater increase the amount of fact in
the humilating at the site of injury
whereas my tour tempo quenched it so
there is a need for calcium to go in and
upon the calcium entry to the
mitochondria there is then a subsequent
increase for empress mitochondrial class
to be formed in order for the repair to
happen in a healthy cell and we can
enhance that further or by increasing
acutely increasing the amount of cross
or we can prevent it by completely
depleting mitochondrial cross by using
drugs so what might the mechanism be or
how could Empress be helping with
repairs this evidence from Keith Burgess
luxury that Ross activates row way by
acting on a specific cysteine residue
oxidizing the cysteine residue which
locks this molecule in an active state
without a gtp s icon so we thought maybe
a row is getting activate at the site of
injury so we use this row a flare sensor
which is a fret place sensor reporting
on the raw activity in a resting cell
you get minimal activity in the lambda
coding inactive lambda for yet but once
you injure the cell and any of these
surfaces you see a probably burst within
ten to thirty seconds a burst of Rahway
activity which is quantified here and
this raw activity is quenched is has
blocked if you quest
mitochondrial dross
I use a minor tempo so it appears that
the sequence of Amanda's calcium entry
leading to Andres production leading to
Roy reactivation and draw is a direct
regulator a fact and colonization
so from ABS could you want to check this
if this pathway which we see families
that worked out in a mono nucleate cell
also holds true in Maya fiber which are
multinucleated cells with a very
different architecture and for that what
he did was he looked in this mouse then
expresses life act in the most muscle
fibers and labeled for the mitochondrial
dross by using - ox and simultaneously
imaged in the same fiber what is the
status of mitochondrial Ross production
and active accumulation and as you can
see from this large image you could act
in accumulation right around the region
where there is an accumulation of
mitochondria across production and they
if you look at just or time the barrel
almost identically to each other and
again the same suspects an to my sin and
my tempo activator of mitochondrial Ross
and venture of mitochondrial ross are
able to show the opposing effects on
actin accumulation and the ability of
the fibers to repair so if any of
questions my template is about two three
four degrees in number of fibrous that
fail to repair so the results are hold
true from single cells to multinucleated
Maya fibers they they seem to be using
mitochondria for the process of
signaling locally for the purpose of
acting accumulation and represent
getting it there so another question
Maria villa in broking in collaboration
with dr.
nagaraj of longtime collaborator a
children's got interested in this in
this observation of atom because she
what she was looking at was this disease
I told you about earlier Duchenne
muscular dystrophy by using a mouse
model called MTX only MVS Mouse their
lack of dystrophin causes myofibril
damage until repair
so what her that I was showing was these
MDX mice had reduced mitochondrial
activity
this is cytochrome C activity and also
Purvis what medic on the content has
measured by my under structure proteins
Tom 20 and v-tach which shows all
production in it so we started looking
at how the deficit in mitochondria might
be manifesting in these addition mouse
model fibers so what what we looked at
was the response of mitochondria in the
MDX muscle and he can see in response to
the injury in the healthy muscle you get
this robust increase and this
mitochondria and disease muscle the Shen
Mouse mortal muscles they don't
accumulate as much there's a significant
reduction in how much mitochondria and
it respond to injury and on top of that
what she was able to see was the other
proteins this is fernanda interacting
proteins and axons in caviola and they
tend to increase as the disease
progresses or disease initiates in the
ndx model is these are two different DMT
model MDX with a one allele another
ideal both lacking district an
expression in both cases as you see the
district is missing the amount of this
ferlyn goes up amount of an X and one
next into kabuna they all seem to be
coming down so the vesicle mediated
repair pathways up regulated in this
Mouse
fibers whereas the mitochondria is down
regulated so this game was a nice model
to ask the question is
vesicle mediated repair pathway The
Cranberries of kept us from repairing
myofibers or as mitochondria have a role
to play so since these are upregulated
if this is the most important mechanism
for repairing myofibers we should get an
improved repair of these myofibers if
mitochondria has a more important role
to play then we should see had reduced
repair of Maya fibers so she went ahead
and checked that she looked for what the
status of a myofibril repair and this is
again videos and stills from there and
showing that healthy Maya fiber the
disease my apart within DHS YouTube
takes up
autumn or die
don't play this video because it is so
dramatic that it hurts - how much die it
takes up and as a result of the
dystrophin deficiency itself the fiber
hyper contracts more violently than even
the dispersion one that I showed you
before and she went out to check this
further non know he by laser injury but
also by using eccentric exercised so she
took muscles out and exercise them and
looked at loss in muscle force in
response to one two three four and so on
multiple muscle contractions and so the
MDS seems to drop much faster compared
to the wild type and digs up lot more
died another member in Permian title of
broken orange it takes a lot more of
that even in response to one or multiple
contractions so the miles LIBOR clearly
seems to be getting its membranes plus
membrane damaged as a result of by the
contraction or laser injury and getting
crater damaged and allowing greater die
entry than the healthy healthy muscle
fibers so and you can see that the
number of fibers that managed to repair
it's a significant significantly reduced
and there's dystrophin deficiency so it
sort of led us to this leading us to now
believe that in case of dystrophin
deficiency it's not up regulation of
vesicle repair that will improve the
disease but a regulation of of the
mitochondrial pathology or non
traditional pathology might have come up
graduation one hundred function that
might still get repair so we haven't
gone on a test any therapies yet
these are very recent findings but we
are an on the process and look at how we
can help the just like we did for that
this fern fiber South Indian actually
happen to shine fibers with that better
so just could you to summarize then
really what I've been telling you is I
started off by showing you model
regarding membrane compare that was
limited to a vesicle mediated by the
patching or provision of extra membrane
we've added since then and others have
contributed significantly to it other
modes are repaired either by way of act
in accumulation and next and I didn't
have this to tell you the story but
we've looked at the role of various and
accidents in the process of repair and a
nextons have been implicated in the
process of repair this is an from an
article by Norwest Irish through but
nice reviews summarizing various models
of it which came up 2015 and it also
talks about the escort and the hazard
sphingomyelin aids as as two important
regulators either appendicitis or ecto
psychosis facilitating membrane
remodeling for the repair process and
synaptotagmin or snare mediated repair
pathway which we looked at in astrocytes
but it's we've not drills much into it
in this talk I don't talk about that
either but all of these are sort of
complementary pathways that facilitate
the stabilization if you go off the
membrane of the damaged NAND gate for
the process of repair in addition to
that what I should spend some time
telling you about is the role of
mitochondria that dovetails into this
act in other processes by way of
signaling so you have a signaling
process that goes on in the repair and
then you have all these structural
processes that need to go on so that
repair happen and so this was not
covered there because more recently but
what I would like to leave you with with
refers to the mammals is this is this
may not be the end of it we are still
very actively in the process of
discovering me and others actively in
the process of discovering what other
pathways might be involved in the repair
process and just from realizing there if
there are these multiple different
pathways I've given you example one
diseased tissue and muscle dystrophy or
another one this for this word and
evidence your lindoro muscular dystrophy
to be where vesicle mediated or
mitochondrial mediated repair pathways
might be deficient and hence can lead us
to therapy and so the last soft closing
slide that I'll give you into luster the
data itself summary of the data is is
this model there you have a case of
healthy muscle you have vesicle fusion
not necessarily form a - but to release
this enzyme as with myelin aids lack of
which when the dis firm these blue
cylinders are missing lack of which
causes
you secretion and we can rescue it by
providing single magnets on the outside
which then will then facilitate these
fibers to repair efficiently or in case
of dystrophin deficiency where the
mitochondria themselves are
dysfunctional because of lack of
dystrophin
and excess calcium influx and that might
set in this poor repair leading to more
calcium influx leading to greater
pathology and so on which causes this
positive feedback causes greater of
myofiber death even when the next send
is for mediated vesicle repair pathway
is upregulated in these fibers and so
Serapis that target these mitochondria
dysfunctional mitochondria might be
beneficial there is evidence of
literature good that is the case
improving mitochondrial function does or
production by the fpdc1 how far is
beneficial in case of the MDX mouse
model so I'll end by I don't need to go
over the summary again since I've
already done this pictorially but by
thanking people who've really been
instrumental for all this work I'm
presenting it to it it's the work of all
of these people have tried mentioning
their name as I went along for people
whose work I was able to present today
but for others whose work I was on I
will present have all contributed
significantly longer the collaborators
many of them very long-standing
collaborators that has resulted in the
both basic science understanding but
also the therapeutic development and all
of this work is supported really vibe by
parish and private foundations including
muscle dystrophy association that just
supported the work our work on looking
at the therapy for it is for not the tea
and grant from knee abscess not
supporting this work even further so
thank you thanks dr. J soir so if you
can
unshare the presentation
it's a really interesting presentation
you have summed up pretty well with the
different the repair of the question
regarding the mitochondrial Mumma Bank
it's not any signal
what makes mitochondria move to the
injury site is there any is there any
signal which injury or is it the calcium
which is drawing the mitochondria to the
site that question would be is it that
whatever the mitochondria within the
cell or is there any piece of
mitochondria happening so let me let me
start with housekeeping question can you
see my screen already you see me okay so
let me ask them and suppository
questions yeah let's start with the
first one what causes my Takagi eight
accumulate to the site of injury so the
weight of my fiber is organized the
fiber contracts the myofibrils contract
as a result of calcium increase and the
calcium in this situation the injury
caught is coming from that tear in the
membrane the damage in the membrane
which causes the myofibrils at the site
of damage to contract the mitochondria
in my african muscle fiber laid along
the microprocessor as the my physical
contract all the mitochondria get both
to get the billet and that provides a
very rapid mechanism for my fibers to
accumulate the mitochondria at the
injury site it does not require a
motor-driven transport which will be far
to store for this causes so that's
that's the mechanism for mitochondrial
accumulation now once it's there under
repair process okay and regarding the
lysosomes and all those things how do
they in terms of mitochondria lysosomes
exosomes and all those things so operate
right so let's let's let's take the best
approach I'm so if you think of
lysosomes what it appears to be doing is
not only providing membrane but more
importantly providing the enzyme swing
violinist
outside and sell to remodel the membrane
test G is the membrane stability
fluidity and allow the lipid mobility to
facilitate the closure of the Moon the
after storms are the exosomes are
primarily in warning shedding membrane
that is damaged as soon as you tear the
membrane out through some sort of
mechanical or chemical trauma the most
likely all of us hasta immigrants to
mitochondria and others that are
happening will oxidize the lipid
oxidized lipids cannot then be used to
close a wound because that at least
implies membrane so you need to get rid
of that and excess on the next stones
that are forming there will facilitate
the process of getting rid of that lipid
and then allowing the remaining healthy
lipids if you grow it close up the hole
as the process of acting mediated repair
allows the membrane we can stretch it
back in with the current technology me
if you look at lysosomes mitochondria
that's by labeling these things at a
time same time so we yeah we can do
multiple different probes simultaneously
I showed you a few examples that we
looked at at and rath mitochondria and
actin so we we've done lysosomes with
other compartments other ender stones
and other things so yes so we can look
at multiple different compartments
simultaneously the nice thing is that
the response is so robust it's so
precise about its timing that oftentimes
we don't even have to do that we don't
even have to look at everything up there
all at the same time we can do them
sequentially and since the repair
happens in the space strip tentative 60
second time interrupt Italy we can time
them and so in the escort paper that I
did not have the time to go over we've
actually timed when does the first
molecule second molecule and third
molecule come in the process of
recruitment of this entire complex and
just by looking at the time process we
were able to say who's in each
who's the follower and then by doing
siren immediate knockouts we were able
to confirm that independently so that
the whole process finished here talking
very strict in its temporal manner
allowing us to do this either in
combination or independently and then
combining it together thank you so much
I think we are just over the time right
now and I get you coming in spite of
your throat and so I really appreciate
that and if you have some good results
shoot an email and we'll get back and
have another hangout sometime so again
thank you so much I appreciate your time
my question for this option how was I